Donald Trump's completely incompetent coronavirus
advisor, Dr. Scott Atlus, has now suggested
that, you know what?
Maybe people should just go ahead and have
the big indoor Thanksgivings this year because
it might be the last Thanksgiving for lots
of people anyway.
Now, I read the headline and I thought, this
can't be true.
It can't actually be that bad.
Let me look at the video.
I then watched the video and it's even worse
than the headline when you actually see the
complete disregard for human life, the complete
lack of empathy, the complete lack of understanding.
The video is worse than the headline.
Let's take a look.
And just as a reminder, who the hell?
Scott Atlus.
Scott Atlus is the doctor that when Trump
pushed Foushee out from being sort of publicly
part of his inner coronavirus circle, appearing
with him at press briefings and the like,
when Foushee was pushed out, Scott Atlus was
brought in.
Now, Scott Atlus is not an epidemiologist.
He's not an infectious disease doctor.
He's not a pulmonologist and immunology.
He's he's a radiologist.
And he has become Donald Trump's top guy on
coronavirus.
Why?
Because he'll simply go along with anything
Donald Trump says.
Take a look at this.
They're suffering from both isolation and
this kind of isolation is one of the unspoken
tragedies of the elderly who are now being
told, don't see your family at Thanksgiving.
For many people, this is their final Thanksgiving,
believe it or not.
What are we doing here?
I think we have to have a policy which I have
been advocating, which is a whole person,
whole health policy.
It's not about just stopping cases of covid.
We have to talk about the damage of the policy
itself.
So what is the federal government do?
It's what I've advisedc.
So that is a neuro radiologist advocating
for things.
What this guy is just disgusting.
And, you know, when I want to talk about infectious
disease, I don't typically think to call a
radiologist.
This is no offense to radiologists.
We have a handful of radiologists in our audience
that I know about.
We probably have more radiologists in our
audience that I don't know about.
Two of them actually emailed me and they said,
David, you know, I don't find it offensive
when people say, why the hell is the radiologist
up there on Trump's coronavirus task force
so prominently?
They wrote to me and said, I'm a radiologist.
I have no business dictating public health
policy during a global pandemic period.
Why is Scott Atlas doing anything?
Here is question number one, Stanford University,
which is where Scott Atlas was a senior fellow
at the Hoover Institution before joining Trump's
coronavirus team has already distanced itself
from Scott Atlas's comments.
Political observers who have some connection
to reality have been criticizing Scott Atlas's
presence in this group.
And what Scott Atlas doesn't seem to be saying
is that we might make this Thanksgiving the
last one for lots of people if we hold these
huge indoor gatherings, which will.
Spread the virus and will kill people who
could have otherwise had many more Thanksgivings.
Now, it's also sort of strange.
Scott Atlas talks about the elderly.
Some of these elderly folks might be on their
last Thanksgiving, regardless of whether there
was a pandemic or not.
Remember the death rate for coronavirus triples
for those in their 60s relative to those in
their 50s.
And then the death rate almost triples again
for those in their 70s relative to those in
their 60s.
People in their 50s, 60s and 70s often live
a long time, like if you're 59 and you have
a significantly higher death rate than those
under 50 when he says the elderly might be
dying in the next year anyway.
Is he talking about fifty nine year olds?
Is he talking about sixty five year olds?
Is he talking about 75 or like what is he
even talking about here when he says this
may be the last Thanksgiving anyway for lots
of these folks who are at higher risk if they
contract coronavirus delusional, completely
delusional.
And this is the doctor who has Trump's ear.
If you say, well, there's all these different
people who are doing good work, Peter Hotez
and you know, Dr. Anthony Fauci and our friend
Isaac Bogosity, who's in Canada.
I mean, the point is there's so many doctors
doing good work and talking sense here.
And it's Scott Atlas who has Donald Trump's
ear.
Once again, it's the worst people.
I previously said almost any random American
would have better handled coronavirus than
Trump.
And you might be wondering, well, like how
would a construction worker or an accountant
or a preschool teacher or a dental hygienist?
Like what?
What do you mean?
How would they have handled it better than
Trump?
Most people would not be so delusional, delusional,
narcissistic that they would think they know
more than doctors.
Most people would just say, wow, I'm in charge
of the pandemic.
Great.
What kind of doctors and public health officials
and scientists know about pandemics?
Let's turn it over to them.
And you would end up with a better situation
than what we ended up with.
Trump did worse than random people by imposing
his ignorance and his delusions and his narcissism
on the situation.
You are seeing the same thing now with Dr.
Scott Atlus.
Almost any doctor would better handle this.
My dentist, who has been my dentist since
I was five years old.
If you put my dentist in charge, my dentist
would immediately say, great, let's bring
in an epidemiologist.
Let's bring in a public health expert.
Let's bring in an infectious disease expert,
a pulmonologist, a medical, you know, whatever
you guys tell me what to do, what to say,
and we'll get it done.
Any one of the doctors on Joe Biden's coronavirus
task force, even oncologist and medical ethicist
Zeke Emanuel, would better handle this than
the combination of Scott Atlus and Donald
Trump.
They regularly find the worst people to do
the absolute worst things all the time, like
clockwork.
And remember, one of the selling points about
Donald Trump was this is a businessman, sort
of like a project manager.
He'll hire the best people.
He'll put the best people in charge.
And it's all going to be fantastic.
There were very few even ostensible selling
points about Donald Trump.
The ones that there were were bogus.
He's failed on every single one of them, including
famously, I will hire the best people and
put the best people in positions of power.
We will be lucky to now get out of this with
under I mean, you know, we're looking at 400000
Americans dead by February, maybe even more.
We will be lucky to keep the numbers that
low.
And at one point, remember, Donald Trump said
forget about 15 cases will soon be zero.
At one point when this was a thing, Donald
Trump was saying, we might lose fifty or sixty
thousand people, but it's not going to be
more than that.
We're looking at four hundred thousand, maybe
even half a million.
Let me know where you are on the next three
months of the virus via Twitter, where you
can find me at de Pakman